qué podemos esperar que se siga
Estableciendo un conjunto de estrategias
frente a lo que llama Turquía la
cooperación internacional realmente
desde el año 2017 el empezó a tener aquí
su agencia que es la tica relacionada
con la cooperación turca ya tiene un
poder grande en países como México chile
Brasil la presencia en países como
Colombia también eso Por una parte que
son mecanismos muy importantes de
acercarse a otras culturas
la mayoría de países latinoamericanos
también le interesaba mucho el tema de
las telenovelas turcas eso ha generado
unos vínculos comerciales y ha permitido
que el turismo latinoamericano sea
potencializado en los últimos cinco años
en más del 20% por este nuevo vínculo
que se tiene más culturales
pero generan recursos y réditos
económicos fuertes y lógicamente es
miembro de algunos grupos de integración
interesantes Como por ejemplo los países
tíbets donde están países como Colombia
Indonesia Vietnam Egipto Turquía
Sudáfrica que tratan de hacerle un
contrapeso fuerte al g7 eso Por una
parte está también en el grupo buscando
Ingresar a los brics Brasil Rusia India
China y Sudáfrica Entonces eso le
permite también ser un jugador cada vez
más visible y también Busca como minar
un poco la relación que tiene en Estados
Unidos y México ya que está haciendo
unas inversiones bastante interesantes
allá entonces qué podemos esperar que la
cooperación cada vez sea más cercana que
se pueda dar unos vínculos comerciales
más grandes y sobre todo las visitas que
se están viendo de alto nivel entre
gobierno y gobierno se han multiplicado
y obviamente eso va a ser que en los
próximos años también sea uno de los
enfoques más grandes frente América
Latina